alerte aux 16 mètres on relancera le
bâtiment là c'est moins 5 pouces 5 à 25
mètres de centrales alerte alerte alerte
deux aérien on éclaire ouverture de
coffre
toutes les trois
c'est l'heure de fermer le panneau de
fermer la boîte comme on dit dans le
jargon
le central opérationnel c'est le poste
de pilotage une dizaine d'hommes s'y
relaient jour et nuit à droite les
opérateurs sonar et les navigateurs sont
en charge de la trajectoire à gauche ce
sont les commandes avec la barre et le
barreur de renforts anthony l'infirmier
comme tous les sous mariniers il a
plusieurs casquettes
ça devrait pas tarder effectivement bon
ça prend les dispositions
les deux alertes
venir à 16 mètres balancer le bâtiment
assiette moins 5 + 5 à 25 mètres
du personnel sous les panneaux 40 des
chasses rapide des goupilles nous sommes
en route aux 2/3 sacré les moteurs avant
2 kevin le maître de centrales
communique avec l'arrière où se trouve
le réacteur nucléaire qui alimente la
propulsion de 130
nous avons
le ksk de veille et le ps code attaque
nous sommes clairs ouverture de khon
comment des purges déverrouiller au
centre un bâtiment tout plongé paris a
plongé se veut être on veut être en
confiance quand le bâtiment seuls les
ordres retentissent les visages sont
concentrées alerte 16 mettre en balance
dans le bâtiment la 7 - 5 e pour 5 à 25
mètres de centrales alerte alerte alerte
deux aérien avec les ouvertures de
coffres mairie fonctionne à tous les
trois
central
presque une chape de plomb qui tombe au
montant est très attentif
les discussions sont codées
obéissent à des consignes strictes
justement pour que tout le monde sache
bien faire au fur et à mesure tous
espèce de théâtre en fait on ne maîtrise
et plusieurs acteurs de la pièce est soi
même ce qui va se passer on dit
habituellement discret musulmans parce
que tous seront l'ambiance générale de
mentionner
le bâtiment étant plongée désormais
invisible en surface indétectable à
l'infrarouge et aux ondes radar sa
position soumises au secret défense la
mission ne fait que commencer